- You are so cute!
Check our your nails, your
rings, your outfit, your hair!
- Thank you!
- You're so cute!
- I really wanted to bring it for you.
- Oh my God
- Kelly Clarkson.
- Have y'all ever met,
have y'all ever met before?
(applause)
- And Jeff Goldblum, I was like,
"Jeff's on the show, I'm getting tips".
You know what I mean?
I was like, I better get tips.
- Have you ever heard, do
you know what a Zaddy is?
Apparently he's a Zaddy.
- Yes I do know what a Zaddy is.
- You did?
I am so old apparently, I did
know what that meant, yeah.
- You know, it's like a Zadday.
- [Kelly] A Zadday.
- And that's, I mean that is
definitely Jeff Goldblum.
- I agree with it,
I just didn't know what it was at first.
So, you are on Broad City
and it was a comedy duo.
So how what that breaking off,
you been doing that
show since 2009 I think.
It's been a part of your life.
And that's a long to work with someone
and all of a sudden
you're like on your own.
- It's crazy to look
back, I'm 32 and like,
10 years is pretty much
a third of my life.
And my partner Abbi Jacobson and I,
give it up for Abbi, woo!
(applause)
Abbi!
Yeah Abbi and I started
the web series in 2009
and it's just been this
climb and climb to the show.
We had five seasons, 50
episodes on Comedy Central
and we created it together and show-ran it
and produced it and we're
so proud of the show
and it's my favorite show.
- And it's kinda cool
because it didn't end
because of anyone else, it ended
because y'all wanted it
to end, which is rare.
- Thank you, Kelly Clarkson yes, I get it.
- I'm just saying that's rare,
usually people are like, "No, more".
And you're just like, "We're done".
- And also women don't usually
get to be like, enough!
In all the ways.
- I do, you should be in my life.
- I should hang out with you more.
This was, I think the first
time, Abbi and I both,
were like, you know what,
this is a good time to end it
and it keeps that power
in the show that we already have created.
- Yeah, so what were you like as a kid?
Were you both talkative?
'Cause you both, even
though you might not be
a standup comedian, you're
a very comedic actor.
Like so were y'all, and
you're very friendly,
we're y'all both like this as kids?
- Where'd you grow up?
- Pittsburgh.
- Oh gotchu.
- You?
- Long Island.
- Everyone cool
is from Long Island!
- Really?
- That's cool.
- Yeah I didn't know that.
- Yeah like Long Island, New Jersey,
that whole area.
But were you always this talkative?
Or were you introverts when you were kids?
- I was talkative, my brother and I,
my brother Elliot is also a comedian,
and we would make sketch
videos for hours, and hours.
I've always been a comedy
nerd, and that's it.
- That's awesome.
- (laughs) That's all I am.
- Were you always this talkative,
you knew everyone right off the bat?
- No, No.
I was very, I was sort of, I needed to be
a good boy in school, I made good grades.
I was kinda, properly--
- [Kelly] Strict household?
- Huh?
- You said good little boy,
was it a strict household?
(Ilana laughs)
- They were kind of strict,
there was some kind of,
serious demand that we be
well behaved in one area
or another, and school certainly.
So I was kinda constrained.
So it was a kind of an outlet,
when I found myself,
I had to find my voice
by and by as I'm still doing,
but I remember, I had a talent
for drawing and painting,
and my dad would take us
to this special art class,
me every week and waiting
outside the Carnegie Mellon,
the Carnegie museum,
when he hadn't shown up yet,
and I would do this thing,
that I can't believe I did,
I was like 11, or 12, I would see people,
and then pretend to know them.
To go, "Oh my gosh, look who it is!".
(laughter)
And I would--
- I think there's a word for
that, it's called stalker.
- That is so strange.
- It's strange, it's strange isn't it?
- You were 14?
- Yeah, 14 or 11, or 12, or something.
- What a bizarre level of agency.
To grown-ups, to adults.
- Do you think it was to make you feel
more comfortable that you
were alone in that moment?
- I don't know.
- Wow someone goes to therapy.
- I think it was me--
- Okay, okay I see you Kelly Clarkson.
- Hashtag truth!
- No it was the seeds
of something creative.
- Yeah that's so interesting.
I was just wondering where
everybody kinda comes from
and their background,
but tell us about your
upcoming comedy tour!
- My tour in March is a standup tour,
and I'm going to nine
cities around the country,
and I'm really excited
about getting out the word
to vote this year, it's 2020.
It's a big year.
(applause)
And I always just want to say,
I am just starting to understand
what the Census is,
and why it's important.
But that's also important this year,
so at my standup shows, we're gonna have,
we're partnering with
HeadCount to register voters,
and then I'm staying an
extra night in each city,
to throw a voter empowerment dance party
with my political organization generator--
- That's awesome!
- So we're gonna dance
for the right to vote.
(cloud clapping)
- That's awesome!
Because here's the thing,
it's vote for who you love,
vote for what you believe in, but vote!
That's important!
And especially, I always
get upset when I have
female friends that don't.
'Cause it's like do you know hard
other women had to fight
for us to have the chance
to be able to do it?
Whoever you vote for, I don't care,
vote for who you want
to vote for, but vote.
- Right, it's the least we can do,
and it's so, it's everything!
- And growing up in a small town,
and leaving and going to
other parts of the world,
you really realize how lucky we are,
so I love that you're doing a dance party,
- Thanks!
- Making it a cool vibe!
- Yeah the whole tour is
called, "Horny for the Polls",
P-O-L-L-S.
(laughing)
- I love it!
- Yeah it's really, it's fun.
Love the clout, thanks.
- Well awesome.